so the philosopher Terence Mckenna had a
fabulous metaphor to express what he
felt was the future of human
communication and he talked about an
organism called the octopi and he says
that for the octave on communication
language was something to be beheld the
octopi Ward's mind outside its skin it
could literally adjust its color to
blend it to its environment to hide from
predators or to communicate with mates
the point being that it's skin was a
dynamic entity that could transform its
colors in a kaleidoscopic frenzy to
express intent to express agency to
express mind so that language became
this thing this three-dimensional thing
in the world and McKenna has said it
from the beginning that the world is
made of language that intentionality is
everywhere expressed in our DNA and in
our behavior not just when we move our
little you know vocal chords and so you
wonder about the future you look at
information technologies you look at the
rise of SMS texting Twitter Facebook you
know FaceTime Skype tech no social
wormholes collapsing distance human
beings finding more and more ways to
interface with one another to express
linguistic intent and agency until the
whole planet becomes cloaked in
mindedness and this is the future
virtual reality technology communication
the mind the interior world turned
inside out expressed as a kind of coral
reef animal that takes over the planet
this is the human agency this is who we
are